Hey YouTubers it's Charlie there's new Supergirl
footage, so this is going to be a breakdown
of that and new round of the giveaways all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I've also got
some Green Lantern news that I'll talk about
after I get through the Supergirl stuff so the whole
point of this trailer is to explain the age
difference between Kara and Superman and a
lot of people are wondering that because she's
supposed to be older than he is the Phantom
zone is the way they explained that which
is also going to be like the story device
that they use for surfacing villains on the
show released extraterrestrial villains I'm
I mean I'm sure they'll be like a like human
villains to genre shows usually veer to metaphors
like that they say things like people can
be just as bad as supervillains from outer
space it's the same thing with Clancy Brown
the flash is just as bad as any the road even
though technically he ends up working with
team flash whenever the reverse flash is getting
ready to suck the earth into a giant time
vortex it's time to put differences aside
in case you haven't seen, they're premiering the show a
little bit earlier than we thought they would
it's going to be October 26 now it'll be a
Monday night show originally wasn't going
to be to till the beginning of November  here we
get a nice shot of Superman I like the compromise
that they don't show his face but they let
him be in the pilot if you try to ask the
question  why can't Superman be on
TV  you're just going to give yourself a headache
so just just forget about it DC and Warner
Bros. just want you to think about the Henry
Cavill Superman they don't want you have any
other broadcast related distractions thus
no face I really am excited about all those
Phantom zone business week we haven't spent
a lot of time there in the TV universe yet
and I that the flash is figured out special-effects
on a TV budget I thought I think there a lot
of places they can go at this there's some
unique challenges the doing a kryptonian show
in that the villains have to be just as strong
as the superhero and when you're nigh indestructible
it's really hard to find a convincing villain
and a lot of people are always wondering why
Barry Derps a lot on the flash like what you
know why he doesn't have all those powers
like right away why can't phase immediately
it takes a while to figured out that's, to
be the same thing with characters are I'll
care Danvers will be a human name but like
she explains in the trailer her mission is
to protect her cousin Kal El but obviously
she gets there he's already been around for
about 25 years so he doesn't need her help
that's a feed the you know what the hell do
I do with my life storyline like ocean it
does this planet need me what am I supposed
to do year but am I supposed to do with my
life the only issue I take with that it is
the idea of superheroes waking up and not
wanting their superpowers that's nine this
not the case here the flash did a really good
job of addressing that's I'm hoping Supergirl
kind of follows up on that theme one of the
really fun things about kryptonian especially
Supergirl in the comics is that she doesn't
pull punches like Superman does this version
of the character is much more nascent like
the one in the trailer that we see is not
super angry yet which is really what it takes
for Superman and any other kryptonian's to
go crazy on people the brief tease of the
action sequences really don't do it justice
they smash the ship Addison sets I go so far
as to say is that was one of the hardest things
for them to figure out like how does she fight
because is not to be crawled my God like all
over it is not to be like down and dirty is
not to be like Barry where he just super speeds
around people Superman by contrast is one
of those characters that doesn't really need
to be a good fighter because he is a God so
a lot of the fun of his fights are the unexpected
ways in which he uses his powers to hand clap
is one of my favorite it's it's a lot like
the flash finger snap or the reverse flash
finger snap I should say they didn't do that
on the flash season one so maybe the bring
it out and season two so I think we'll start
to see her get way more creative with their
powers towards the end of the season this
is a good question which new power do you
want Kara to get by the end of the season
that we haven't see on TV or in the movies
yet a lot of my hope for this show is that
though do something really interesting with
the Phantom zone which is a
place haven't spent a whole lot of time with
in the TV and movie universes there aren't
a lot of preconceived notions about that other
than the fact that they used to banish criminals
there anyway it's going to be a lot of fun
I'm  really looking forward to the series
generally like when series 1st start out
I have pretty low expectations usually season
to season three is one stuck as crazy so you
just had to be patient Gotham was not so hot
when it first started out but season two is
actually looking pretty bad ass I'll be doing
some Gotham videos to pretty soon but onto
Green Lantern stuff Tyrese is teasing that
he might be part of Green Lanterns if that really
is the direction they're going with the franchise
I'd be totally open to that John Stewart is a
great character obviously they always
want to go with Hal Jordan first because he's
the Green Lantern that everybody knows and
it's all about familiarity when you're trying
to launch a movie but this is potentially so far
off in the future that it doesn't really matter
that much most the focus is going to be on Batman
v Superman appropriately at comic con but do
not be surprised they drop info about the other
movies like Aquaman Green Lanterns and the
flash team up movie the most interesting thing
about the flash movie is is being written
by Lorde and Miller the guys that did the
lego movie basically Lego movie and 21 Jump
Street by the time we get to that though Grant Gustin will have been the flash for like five
years so he will for all intents and purposes be
the the Barry Allen we're familiar with
and don't forget to the Warner Bros. TV panel
is also going to drop a bunch of legends of
tomorrow stuff so I'll probably be doing a
new legends of tomorrow video soon so much
stuff happening this weekend I'll try get
the Supergirl review up as fast as possible
hopefully by Saturday at least I have a Spider-Man
villain video and I'll be doing some Arkham
Knight gameplay on my game channel links for all
the important stuff down in the description
below but while you wait for everything to post
you can click here to learn all about the
flash season two and Arrow Season 4  premiers and
you can click here for my game of thrones
Q&A that I just posted last night thank you so much
for watching everybody, let's High Five and
I'll see you guys tonight